it's a deep thinking Wednesday on the
askgaryvee show weird
hey yeah that pretty much summed me up
deep thing but I don't know what the
[ __ ] day of the week is on this
episode we talk about pinterest sad
product and then we got really really
really deep you ask questions and I
answer them
this is the askgaryvee show
[Music]
hello everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 85 of
the askgaryvee show feeling pretty good
went to San Francisco yesterday going to
Copenhagen tomorrow night
got Madrid next week so doing some
serious world travelling the beard is
coming in nicely though Ajay's fiancée
Ali threw me for a curveball the other
night where she really innuendo through
her body language that she didn't want
the beard for the wedding which is June
11th I think so that is a that's thrown
a curveball in my strategy of growing
this out until the Jets lost so got to
really decide if I want to be a good
brother-in-law or or do I want to be I
don't know difficult what else is going
on nothing too much Mirek having got a
bunch of cameras here that they've set
up with phones which i think is really
rad I'm enjoying kind of looking at that
enjoying the show been uh been really
happy with the new Wine Library TV
design getting a lot of emails and
tweets from all of you that liked
watching me back and they taste wine so
that's fun super pumped about the Jets
was proud of myself of getting Duke and
Maryland in the finals kids are growing
up my fantasy baseball team had a great
opening day I'm in second place after
one day and I think I'm ready for the
show
so I like this you know do you remember
to like episode 30 I was like oh I got
to do more like cup of coffee like like
Regis and Kelly action that was a little
bit of that that was fun I have nothing
to hear either weird uh alright India
let's get into the show no I don't need
a problem I am a prop in myself my
personality is a problem Geoff ass
there's buzz around Pinterest
advertising and they're slowly letting
invisi counts are you optimistic Jeff
this is a great question you know we
haven't talked enough about Pinterest on
the askgaryvee show so I appreciate the
question
good job India of picking that out I'm a
I'm a huge believer in Pinterest product
you might have noticed very recently
that they've made it
a term of service that you can't do
affiliate sales my belief is that mean
that they are now gonna turn that on for
themselves and if you start thinking
about the amount of Commerce that goes
on on Pinterest even if they make 5% of
every transaction it could right away be
one of the top five to ten companies and
revenue in the digital space I'm a big
believer in the business and seeing
what's going on with faith box Willie
and Co company we've incubated at
vayner/rse just like four dollars an ad
spending on promoted pins some of the
stuff we've seen at vaynermedia the
stuff I'm seeing from Wine Library I'm a
a massively bullish I actually think the
Pinterest's ad product a year from today
let's call it 18 months from today we
will recall this video somebody make a
note put into your calendar from 18
months from today we will make a video
or a piece of content however we do it
in those days 18 months from now to talk
about this video where I make this claim
which is that pincus's ad product is a
major competitor to Google AdWords for
econ businesses that are digital focused
enormous ly passionate about Pinterest
ad product and I highly recommend
everybody watching this if you're
selling something on a.com that you get
very serious about understanding what's
going on in a Pinterest environment
bullish would be an understatement what
super bullish so bro like I'm into it
Benjamin s like you I believe there's so
much to be gained from social media but
what do you think we have lost or named
or losing but I think this is a great
question and I haven't given this a lot
of thought because the truth is I'm such
an optimist and and the truth is I think
most people default into cynicism and
pessimism that I think I allow those
people to do that work for me but what I
do think about the one thing that is
interesting to me is I do feel that all
of us especially the ones that decide to
participate in putting out content which
if you look at the data may not be at
full full scale in the 70s and 80s and
90s gets bigger as you go down and as
the younger you get the more you're
really putting out content whether in
private form
or public forum I think the most
interesting thing is that I think we're
losing peace of mind and that's
different than privacy I think that we
all now know we're living a life on the
record whether we decide to put it out
there in selfie form or if we just
happen to be in the background of
somebody doing it and what that does is
it makes us all kind of be on the record
tensa right we're we're in PR form I
think a lot of us are living the PR
version of our lives
to the public it's always the pictures
of us at concerts and on trips people do
share you know my my facebook feed is
really basically the extremes and maybe
that mean I'm evolving my answer here I
think we're losing the middle maybe I'll
change my answer because when I think
about what's happening is everybody's
like look at me I'm at a Beyonce concert
front row right by the way massively
interesting data that I'm looking at of
why people are now going to public
events just to take the selfie to say
they were there which is why concert and
sporting events it's amazing how social
is making the real world business go up
but then number two I see a lot of
people in my facebook feed and my Social
Feeds sharing their tragedies you know
literally yesterday's Facebook scroll
which I do occasionally was literally
like people announcing that they've
become sick or pictures of their
daughter with open heart surgery just
these real extreme emotions and then the
other things which is like I'm at Bora
Bora and I'm living the best life and
I'm pouring champagne down my throat the
middle is getting kind of squeezed as we
are going to social and I think we meet
on eclis the middle is peaceful right
the middle is less tense
the middle is relaxing the little lacks
tension and so for me I'm good because I
need insanity like right now I'm pissed
as you may notice behind me we've opened
up a 12th floor
[Music]
that's right here rock you're gonna go
down there and film some 12th floor and
that hurts me because now the insanities
down a little bit but I recognize that
I'm an anomaly of somebody who needs to
blasts Weezy songs at full blast for a
six hour flight to San Francisco
yesterday to get off and be able to do
my thing I worry about the people that
are more centered or introverted in this
environment where we're getting
suffocated by storytelling and our
public personas whether we intend to do
it or we've come a byproduct of it so I
think separating our our public life to
our private life is gonna become more
and more difficult than we're losing
that that it was just a hell of a lot
easier back in the day ironically keep
it rolling ironically I think that's
where snapchats winning
I think snapchat is content of the
middle like if you think about it the
[ __ ] you put on snapchat you'd never
make an Instagram photo right like it's
just the [ __ ] that just you don't care
because it goes away you don't care
about the lighting you like it's just
it's just you know it's almost the
closest thing to real life
Todd Karl ass I've been in sales for
over 20 years and I've excelled at being
able to read people's body language but
how do you do that over the Internet
or on social media Todd first of all
into you're crushing this episode or
maybe you vaynernation forgot you India
you vaynernation are crushing this
episode with the questions the the truth
is I love this question I love it
because I'm freaked out by the answer
and look this falls very much into
bravado and ego but you know that's part
of me too
I've been blown away by my ability to
make that transition I too did
everything the way you did I stood in a
floor I watched I read I do it all the
time it's why I love Q&A it's why I love
public speaking it's why I don't have a
set presentation I'm reading the room in
real time I'm leaning my staff it's how
I scale my ability to read at scale like
walking through the 12th floor me like
that person's in trouble like it's weird
kind of like I don't even
talking about it it's like a really nice
in a kind of skill that has helped me
scale my personality I for some reason
feel those feelings in people's comments
and tweets now maybe it took me a long
time to get the cadence of course
there's been times where I've maybe read
into it wrong because context and tone
is lost but I've got to tell you my
intuition is if you go hardcore and
trying to do that through Twitter
through your facebook comments on your
posts and this is more about me reading
people responding to my stuff so maybe I
know where the North Star starts but
it's been stunning to me that exactly
what I've done in the real world is how
I scaled Twitter specifically in being
able to read people's motion and asking
for clarity maybe in the real world my
man we don't ask for clarity I won't say
d-roc are you feeling oh you know oh
you're feeling uneasy about this wine
cool let's go in a different direction
maybe I have to ask that a little bit
more tangibly black and white in a
conversation on digital but it's the
same effort same mentality and the
beauty is emojis and short form and
slang have given more context around the
written word online and we as human
beings are great at communicating people
grossly underestimate our ability be
communicators when they're drawing on
caves or making smoke signals or radio
television the written word the internet
commenting emojis were talented at this
and I'm watching all of us evolve you
know very many of us of many of you
who've been romantic about grammar have
finally let it go you know all of us are
misspelling words on purpose so it
autocorrects because we value the speed
we're using emojis from not only to 13
year olds or just people in Asia now it
is worldwide phenomenon we're evolving
and we're great at it and so I I look
for those cues and I keep trying to
evolve and stay ahead of where I think
we're all evolving - hi Gary Ryan here
from on-property comm do you just want
to say thank you because your book crush
it allowed me to go out full-time on my
own my question is why did you start a
service business your agency instead of
starting a media company which is seem
really
that Ryan great question missus all can
you make some sort of like all-time
great episode alert thing here put it in
my hands there's a great question and
it's a very specific detailed answer for
a couple reasons one I'm not sure that I
was aware of how good I was at it five
years ago too
I had an inkling when we started
vaynermedia the first project we worked
on was something called daily one to ten
calm and we were doing facebook fanpages
driving to a tumblr so I was on that
kick from the get but three the most
practical thing was I knew that speed
mattered and that money mattered and
that scale mattered and the agency
client service business was very obvious
to me as the quickest path to scale and
money because now we have Vayner
publishing and we're building out lost
Lederman calm you could check it out we
just bought it wait for the redesign but
we're now starting to get into the media
business and we have the infrastructure
and the scale and the skill set and I
have 500 people that I've been able to
affect with my thinking they've got to
counter that with their own thinking but
clearly as the CEO and a thought leader
in a space I'm sure I'm evolving their
thinking towards a direction that picks
up speed because the more I agree with
them and they agree with me the quicker
we can be at what we need to do and so
really the answer to your question is
because I'm patient you know I thought
the right strategy was to build out an
infrastructure that allowed me to get to
it later plus not to mention media's
evolved enormous Lee in those five years
and if you look at media and the upside
of media and the media sites of today
five years ago they were very predicated
on SEO and SEM something that I never
really loved now were predicated more on
social sharing and content something I
love more and so I think that my
intuition and I'd like to think
rightfully so at the time was I was not
the perfect player for that time but my
intuition was there's a chance that the
market may move into that if I'm in a
certain place in five years to capture
the markets evolution on the media side
perfectly then I can win triple and I
think I'm starting to maybe play out and
to fit on that bat and so I was just
strategic about it
antwuan ass what usually prompts you to
walk away or turn down great
opportunities Antoine I don't want to be
in the business of saying no to great
opportunities I'd like to think that the
answer to the question is my intuition
and I'd like to think my intuition is
allowing me to walk away from bad
opportunities that may look good on
paper you know I just go with my
intuition and there are really nothing
else I mean I'm not an analytical
thinker right I'm not gonna look at a
whole lot of data a lot of these big
funds that try to ask me like well how
did I know this startup was gonna be
great or why did I think this was gonna
be great it was never predicated on a
monthly active users or some sort of
other data set it was me teeth what I
would like to say is that I like to
taste things
it's me observing and then me counter
punching that observation and I tend to
be very very all-in on my intuition and
so that's a you know that's kind of how
I make the calls and so it's funny the
way you asked the question you asked a
question in what I think is more of a
defensive mindset which is if you if you
break down the question it ends with the
real kicker which is running one more
time for me India how do you to me that
never runs through my mind the thought
of like saying no to great opportunities
is just not in I don't put those words
in that pattern of a sentence and so
that is what I think you should be
thinking about it sounds to me that
you're crippled by the myths
I'm not I just keep having the at-bats
and the swings and I I know that I'll
have more wins than losses and if I pass
in something good so be it
but it literally I mean we've talked
about in the show before passing on
ubers angel round twice and leaving 300
million dollars on a table literally
outside of being a great story to tell
you how I feel doesn't come into my mind
ever and rule maybe once in a blue moon
but pretty much never and I think that's
an important thing and an offensive
mindset versus a defensive mindset
something something I want to get deeper
into content team
cool um question of the day what is the
biggest miss of your career what is the
one thing you said no to that worked out
great I had a meeting with the other day
with a woman who passed on being one of
the first 600 or 500 employees at Google
she felt pretty down about it you know
and so I'm fascinated by that and so
give me your answer you keep asking
questions I'll keep answering them
she loved thank you so much for watching
hope you enjoyed it losing that hurts
All Right see ya
you